historically shark attacks on Reunion
have been rare over the previous decade
the annual average was just one incident
but in 2011 the island is in crisis
[Music]
Matthew is actually reunions fifth
victim this year and it's only September
Islanders are in shock it's vitally
important that we find out the reasons
for these attacks there is a real
problem here
we noticed that something was changing
what we didn't know residents are
desperate for answers their safety and
their livelihood is at stake a small
onion lives with tourism if we don't
have tourism tomorrow we'll have nothing
left
so what's triggering this deadly spate
of attacks to find out the French
government calls in leading shark expert
Jeremy cliff clearly the long bells were
signaling five shark attacks of which
two effectively that is a huge spike
cliff believes the first step to solving
this mystery and preventing further
attacks is to identify the species
responsible so he starts by analyzing
Matthew's incident and a chilling detail
stands out he was attacked by two sharks
[Music]
palanca D Tiffany Valerie Thomas if a
model powder flown power/power people
a double shark attack like this is
extremely rare in fact it's thought that
such an event has only been captured on
film once in the year 2000 in South
Africa a teenager is surfing when he
suddenly knocked off his board by one
shot while a second shark attempts to
bite him
incredibly the boys survives
but this tag-team tactic may serve as a
calling card for the culprit in reunion
only certain shark species and together
hammerheads search for food in large
schools that can consist of more than
100 sharks and lemons conduct
coordinated assaults by hurting prey
into one area even black tips hunting
groups in the shallows but cliff thinks
these species are all too small to
inflict the kind of damage that caused
Matthews death while the striking
features of this particular attack is
the severe injuries involved such
ferocity points to a much larger
predator and only two species commonly
found in the region fit that bill
first we have Natasha shock
tiger sharks reach at least 16 feet they
have size in terms of jaws and body size
to be able to tackle large prey and
therefore they won't be scared of
attacking a human yet cliff doubts
tigers are to blame
they are totally solitary animals and
will hunt on their own that leaves only
one possible culprit to explain cliff
turns to footage recently captured off
the coast of Reunion as part of a study
on the behavior of the region's sharks
it depicts one particular species that
apparently plays well with others
the just clear evidence of two fox
swimming together one behind the other
in fact in nearly 20% of occasions
captured on film
they were seen foraging together the
shark seen here are bull shark bull
sharks weigh as much as 500 pounds and
are highly aggressive they typically
attack on their own often head-butting
prey before tearing it to shreds but as
these images reveal they also use
another hunting tactic there's clearly
an advantage to work cooperatively and
there by predation efficiency
based on this evidence Cliff believes
he's identified the type of shark that
killed Mathieu so from that I would
conclude that a bull shark responsible
for this particular attack
[Music]